how's it going reject nation greg here
john here
today we are going to watch the official
trailer
for disney and pixar's luca this is just
shaping up to be my year of
representation on my mother's side
we got shanxi we got mortal kombat
on my dad's side we got sea monsters
yeah well one for asian representation
it's all been strong mortal kombat
can't think of any other any other
movies something that the oscars
happened no italian side you're italian
too so you get some love here
italian i am hey i have a lesser is
happening
in this fight i've got some pride yeah
that's right and also
uh in our last reaction because the the
press release said these were sea
monsters
but someone in the one of the top
comments in our last reaction was
to clarify their sirens i was like
i thought they were just two little gay
italian boys
on any sea monsters i don't know there's
a whole there's the elements
come out of that closet that was hard to
watch
[Music]
the sky clouds the sun whoa
don't look at it definitely look at it
this movie's so colorful
god it's got everything it's got vespas
and football
the losers club check telegram
you're sea monsters aren't you not
sea monsters in my house
[Applause]
wow what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
nope
[Music]
[Laughter]
no oh oh boy
the wrong thing to say all right guys
it's a bold step
for them to do call me by your name too
in animated format that's right
with seamonsers that looks delightful
looks absolutely delightful
it's funny because it's you know it's an
animated movie it's disney pixar and
usually there's like a
a very clear-cut plot some type of high
concept thing where like oh these
characters have a goal to hit this is
who they'll arc into by the end you know
something like that
and i feel like there's something there
but like all
all great movies set in italy it feels
just like a slice of life
yes you know yes exactly it really seems
like it wants to like
in a snappy fashion borrow from those
new wave films and be like oh you're
just hanging out over an idyllic summer
learning and living and coming of age
and also trying to hide from everybody
around that you're a creature
i don't really know what like the what
the abc
plot of this would be it's like you got
these two brothers
who are sirens i guess or scenes
i'm just gonna say sea monsters all
right we're gonna get caught up in the
semantics
right there are these sea monsters feels
like there's gonna be a lot of gags of
water being splashed on them and oh my
god we gotta hide ourselves and those
jokes like oh there's
some fishy about you yeah they take fish
out of water to a whole new level here
don't they
the tone of it just feels like a really
great relaxing time the music
is just so so pleasant like everything
about this is
pleasant and yeah it's such a colorful
trailer
everything about it is just popping yeah
every every little visual bit but at the
same time
i can't really see what like the big
hook would it would what would it be
with this film you know like i'm not
sure there's something that's still
not quite present in the trailer here
for me and i don't know what it is
like i'm sure it's accurately
representing the movie
and it looks really endearing and i'm
sure i'll cry
it's pixar that's where they get you the
tears they're all about the tears i'm
sure there's going to be something there
and it looks
funny and amusing but i'm like what is
that mist there's something
missing there that i can't quite put my
finger on yeah this sort of falls at
least tonally between the two flavors of
pixar for me which is when you get like
a soul or an inside out or a cocoa would
be a better example of like oh this is
like gonna really dive deep into both
the culture but also some really
emotional and
thoughtful stuff and then you have your
other side of pixar where it's like
those elements are there but this is
gonna be more like a fun adventure you
know more traditional animated movie and
i i can't tell which one this is trying
to be
because a lot of the plot elements and a
lot of like the humor does feel kind of
like
a more broadly appealing pixar movie
while
the subtext it seems like this does seem
like it's probably a metaphor for you
know
uh being in the closet to some degree
and learning a journey of
self-acceptance which
can be very profound and very deep and
also it seems like it is
very much plugged into its culture
what what you just talked about about
being in the club i thought it was like
just a
like oh let's just do the puberty angle
but with
the like sea monsters wanted to put that
in there too
really okay but but because it's this
element of like we have to hide our
identities and we can't let anybody in
the normal town know like all the
the best life is over there and we want
to go there and enjoy that but we have
to keep ourselves secret in order
to do that no one can know i guess what
i'm wondering is like with what the
trailers are giving us i feel like with
every pixar movie there's a lesson that
the characters have
usually with most movies especially in
pixar movies
there's a lesson that the character has
to learn or what they have to grow into
and i don't
quite know what that is yeah here it's
like oh they seem fascinated with human
life they're going to experience human
life yeah
is this is this just about the person
going to want to be human like what's
the
worst where's it basically where's it
going yeah but then again it's set in
italy so it could just be a nice slice
of life movie
it literally could just be about hey
luca you need to get out of your head
man yeah stop just
your inner voice and just enjoy life
yeah and hey maybe that'll be it too
like i would love to i would be
interested at least to see a pixar movie
that does take more of that approach
where it is just a slice of life that's
beautiful to behold
yeah that occasionally the one thing
that made me wonder is is i always love
when pixar gets more theoretical with
their animation
and so those moments where he's like
running on saturn's rings and things and
you have these more expressive like most
of the imagery of this
isn't that so i'm like what's that gonna
be and how's that gonna figure in that's
what keeps giving me these hints like oh
maybe this could be one of the great
pixars
or it could just be one of the fun ones
yeah there's just something not being
communicated here in the trailer that i
feel like will be a nice surprise in the
movie itself
so we're gonna see what that is will
there be an antagonist of sorts will
there be an act like a physical villain
i'll just be that comedic
guy who's making the fish it will the
antagonist be
whatever this character has to overcome
there's something there
that i don't i'm maybe you guys picked
up on it let us know
but looks like a solid film let us know
your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button last but not least
shout out some patrons the jedi
bro lauren american horse
peter pacheco joanna saint louis
matthew mensing sandrine little angel
rogue cree sam castle that's j94
good justin martin halo waters rosie
baby dorothea daughter 66
rupee dynamite cal durian z pinnacuz
phillip uh jay smith jr jen smith
ron davidson melhany leblanc
brittany barely natalie doran
roger chase gardner tnh
and evadrastikova thank you guys for
being part of our patreon page and
showing your support
your support has meant a lot and uh
we wouldn't be here still at the real
rejects if it weren't for you guys
and uh hopefully you enjoy the random
[ __ ] that is posted there
and uh i hope to see you guys again next
month
seriously i love you guys thank you i
love you guys
i love you
you